[Musique]
ce vendredi 11 novembre aura lieu la
commémoration des travailleurs engagés
au Lazare et de la Grande Chaloupe
une cérémonie solennelle organisée
depuis 2004 par le département en
collaboration avec plusieurs
associations représentant la diaspora
réunionnaise
en nous donnant rendez-vous à tous ceux
qui souhaitent participer à cette
commémoration vendredi à 9h30 au Lazare
numéro 1
pour tous ensemble partir en procession
vers la mer rendre un hommage à nos
ancêtres qui sont arrivés qui ont
débarqué à la Grande Chaloupe par bateau
donc là chacun association va procéder à
un rituel donc la Fédération tamoul la
Fédération chinoise kafab et les
associations malgaches et ensuite à la
fin de toutes ces cérémonies nous
revenons vers le laser et numéro 1 pour
un temps d'échange
donc là il y aura effectivement les
discours des présidents d'associations
mais aussi des institutionnels et ça
sera l'occasion aussi
d'échanger avec le public et pour
terminer il y aura un temps culturel
donc là le hasard est propose
effectivement au visiteurs de découvrir
les expositions permanentes du Lazaret
sur la thématique de la quarantaine et
de l'engagisme mais aussi de découvrir
le chantier de réhabilitation du
lazarine numéro 2
[Musique]